One of the cool things about the game is that we were trying to capture the feel
of the films. So what we've tried to do is build our,
our maps and our bowel structures so that they are generally plain aligned like
the film, but at the same time it's space. So you can do whatever you want.
So like as a bomber,
it is perfectly valid to fly upside down beneath the star destroyer and be
launching your bottoms upward into the base of the ship.
It lets you have a kind of having taken you to two in terms of feeling like star
Wars, but giving you a lot of control. Hi,
this is Ian Frazier creative director on star Wars squadrons. Hi.
I'm Shadi Melech lead UI artist on star Wars squadrons.
And this is every star fighter it star Wars squadrons,
Fundamentally star Wars. Squadrons is a game about being a pilot,
a combat pilot in the star Wars universe.
So you're going to get into iconic ships like the X wing and the tie fighter
last round in five V five space battles, both in single-player.
We've got a story set after return of the Jedi and a multi-player where we have
two different competitive modes.
So today we're going to look at all 10 playable ships and star Wars squadrons.
We're going to have an in-depth look at their design gameplay and how we stay
true to the film.
Okay.
The fighter class is the multi-role class within star Wars quadrants.
So these are the ships that are good at everything,
but they're not great at any one thing. If you want to be flexible,
able to switch back and forth between offense and defense fighters are where
it's at.
The cool thing with typewriter is,
is one of the ships where we have a lot of references from the films for any of
the eight ships. We would always start by the movies.
That's like the Holy grail.
We would supplement that by looking at schematics drawings and various manuals
that we had grabbing all of that we would do first concept art in
2d. So this is really just like in Photoshop,
grabbing different parts and moving them around rescaling dumb,
addressing all our gameplay needs,
but making sure that we stayed true to star Wars aesthetic and the vehicle
specific character. So for the tie fighter,
it's a ship that actually does have already a nice big central screen.
And we just had to kind of manipulate a few elements that were already existing
in the cockpit to go and create the extra gameplay elements we needed.
We tried to act like we were income. Like we were assigned our fleet systems.
Like we were the fictional companies within the star Wars universe that builds
these ships. We're looking at it partially as game developers,
but partially also from a purely fictional lens and going well,
have you had to really build one of these ships for real?
What would you do running this mixture between the films and trying to capture
the prop,
but then knowing that the prop is a prop and then looking at what it would take
to really fly one of these things.
And then finally knowing that only it's a game.
So there's constraints around that as well.
We tried to take all those things together to end up with the result that you
see today. The biggest challenge with getting the Thai fighter to,
to play the way that we wanted was simply that the design of it is actually
built around this sort of PO porthole window, right?
You have this front facing window that everything's focused around and we need
to make sure the player has enough vision, frankly.
So there was a lot of playing with the distance between where that window is,
where the control column is, where your seat is, so that both in 2d,
and of course in VR,
that the amount of visibility you have there is this kind of maximized,
or we keep the iconic look, fun fact, as we were working on it,
we ran into a problem. The Thai fighter interior,
where the struts are in the window, don't match the exterior.
There was actually a production error in the new hope.
So the inside of the tie doesn't match up with the outside.
The angle of the threats is different. We had to decide which,
which of these is going to be correct. Of course,
being a pilot game focused within the cockpit. We chose the cockpit view.
We needed for gameplay to have additional screens. So we have a central console,
but we've got a lot of gameplay components.
We didn't want it to be too DUI overlay.
We want players to have that pilot fantasy of really using the instruments that
are in the ship. We had to add screens.
We were looking at reference that was outside the period.
And if you look at the first order ties,
they have these arms inside with these triangular screens.
The discussion we had from there was like, well, you know,
this is not the right time period, not the right model.
We don't want to go there,
but could we maybe imagine that there is a prototype of it that's already around.
Timeline?
That's one of the nice things with our time period is we're right after indoor.
So both sides are kind of reappraising what they're doing a little bit.
And we see some interesting technology evolve that makes sense fictionally with
the tie specifically, you'll notice that in the prologue,
which is set around the same time period as the first film,
you don't have any missiles. You don't have any countermeasures.
You have the basic lasers engines, Thai fighter,
but then when we jumped forward to the post end or period where most of the game
has set, now that the tightened squadron, the Imperial group that you're with,
they start experimenting with these shifts and trying things that are a little
bit more out there.
So you're going to get some non-stock options for weapons and components and
stuff. Once you get into that later time period,
the X wing and the tie fighter needed to be quite different.
This is the game that we've tried to balance,
but balance in an asymmetric way because each faction fictionally kind of has
its own strengths and weaknesses.
And we wanted to lean into those and actual game play.
The nice thing the X wing has is it's got all three systems,
it's got its engines,
it's got its lasers and it's got shields that you can shift those double front
or behind you something, you know, we've heard in the films,
but then the tie fighters canonically don't have shields at all. So we said,
okay, what do we do to make that fair,
to get to kind of balance these two ships out, but have similar roles,
but are on opposite factions. And we need to keep, uh, more or less lined up.
If you fly the two in our game, the X wing feels a bit heavier.
It's got a bit more substance to it. The Thai fighter has a zippier turns.
It's just a faster ship and a more easily maneuverable ship.
And so that helps kind of counterbalance the shields in and of itself.
But the ability to control the shields to put them to front or back is giving
another edge to the X wing. So how do we counter that?
What we do is we use the same buttons that we would use for shield control on
the next wing, on a tie fighter. And some of the other ties,
we use that for emergency power conversion,
which is the ability to pull all the juice out of your engines and dump them
into your lasers or vice versa on the fly.
So you can quickly get out of trouble or quickly juice up your weapons for a
massive attack in a hurry in a way that the rebel ships can't.
Some of the things we to do for the X.
Wing were, uh, changing the viewport kind of slimming down the struts a bit.
It's a bunch of invisible changes that make it feel like the movie I had to take
the existing dashboard and, you know, its angular shape and how, how high it is.
That's iconic.
So we obviously have to have that we penned and scaled and kind of moved around
to create additional room.
So we'd be able to fit all the gameplay components for each of these changes.
Basically it's a slide in the deck showing the original,
showing the intended change and justifying why, but any changes we were doing,
you know, using the materials that were already in the cockpit, you know,
paint or icons or buttons that came from elsewhere and just making sure
everything was really authentic to that, that can shift.
Like real things, right? So both from the fictional standpoint,
but also as prompts from the films we would ask, okay, it's 1977, your ILM,
you're building a prop.
You don't have a flat LCD screen and those don't exist yet.
You're going to notice that the lights for your laser charge or actual LEDs,
old-style like a little bowl with a plastic coating over it.
That's coloring the light. It's one of those things that makes the game,
I think, feel more real because the teams tried to approach it as if it is real.
If we were making just any ship just for the game, you know,
from a player experience standpoint, you're gonna put the,
the UI element exactly where you needed the size you,
that you need it in this case,
the fantasy is being a pilot in the star Wars universe.
So it doesn't make sense to do that.
You'd be sacrificing the whole fantasy that, you know,
we're trying to offer players because you're just trying to be as efficient as
possible.
Even once we had the UI there with the right color scheme and everything looking
great in the retro, it still wasn't enough.
We wanted players to feel like they were really there.
So working with shader artists, we went and did materials.
We went to the point of being able to emulate the screen resolution for each
display,
having a refresh rates and keeping the frame rate down to give that retro
choppiness, you know, like to the animation.
So how do we create the sense that these ships are real?
The first thing we did was the flight model for the X wing and Thai fighter.
And everything's really been built upon that foundation.
And what we've tried to do with them is look at everything we see in the films
and even some of the animated series and so on to look at what are the
boundaries? What are these ships capable of? What are they not capable of?
For instance, there's no vertical thrusters on next plane.
They don't go straight up and down. It's not a thing that X winds do.
So we did not want that as part of our flight model because it doesn't fit the
fiction. At the same time, we wanted to create the idea of kind of world war II.
Combat piloting is our foundation as it was for Lucasfilm.
And then from there go, how do we up that a notch?
How do we take things like power management and eventually boosts and the drift
maneuver to take it and really take advantage of the fact that you're in space
and we can do some cool over the top stuff.
We ended up building an entirely new entity to handle how our ships work within
the frostbite engine,
because we knew we were trying to do something that had never been done before
in our engine, quite like what we're doing.
We base it a lot off of the older games,
like original X wing and Thai fighter use that as a starting point, uh,
in terms of the kind of banking maneuvers we wanted to have in terms of how we
wanted them to handle turns. And so on, we did that as a foundation early on,
and then we started layering things in like power management and eventually drip
maneuver and legends.
There was this idea in star Wars of the etheric rudder and this idea that there
was some kind of medium in space that you actually kind of piloted through,
which was sort of the fictional reasoning behind ships handling more like
aircraft, less like spacecraft. Now, honestly,
I don't even know if that's Canon anymore or not. In terms of our,
our thinking around how we make the ships move.
It helps as a visual representation of how ships would move through media.
These are the ships that are meant to go after other Starfighters.
So they're the most agile and fast, and they really pack a punch.
They're also the most fragile. So you have to watch out,
they're not meant to go after capital ships,
when going about designing the time receptor, the idea was at the tie fighter,
the interceptor and into bomber, or they're part of the same line.
And when you're flying Imperial,
there's a certain standard and there is efficiency in the design,
but we did still want each ship to have its own unique character.
The way we did that for the interceptor, it's a ship that's made the hunt,
but it's also more fragile. So it's a little details. Like if you look at the,
the viewport, the spokes, and then the rim around there, thinner, more refined,
giving it a more precise look, but also a bit more fragile.
And the other big thing that we were able to use were those screens that we were
adding on the side that we spoke about earlier.
So each of the three ships got a custom shape.
The one for the interceptor are these kind of aggressive triangles.
They kind of cement, its look as, you know, a hundred.
So one of the most fun parts of working on the cockpits for squadrons was
figuring out how you actually fly a tie fighter.
And this is true for the fighter,
the interceptor and the bomber is that if you look at the films,
we see very little of the actual interior of those ships and how physically you
control it now, an X wing, uh, it's a joystick,
but with the time we see that there's a yoke,
but it's not really clear how that works.
And so we've ended up with this design around the pushing and pulling what it
does when you twist, like what's a pitch, what's a yall.
How do you roll one of these ships and make sure that what we do does it
contradict what we see in the films,
but is internally consistent and makes sense from a player standpoint.
So if you're playing the game,
especially if you're in VR and you look down at what your pilot's hands are
doing, it always makes sense. So when we, we built the ties, uh,
part of figuring out how they would control was sort of the physicality of it.
So we actually built simple wooden armatures that were the controls,
like kind of imagine the yoke of the tie fighter.
So that then when we did motion capture performance capture of our actors for
cinematics, they were sitting inside these simple, you know,
wooden cockpits and then would work on the motions.
We're having a lot of fun with it.
So one of the things that makes the tie still very distinctive from the new
Republic ships and the Thai,
interceptors probably the best example of this is actually the sound design.
So those core mechanics of, you know,
throttling your engine and that sweet spot in the middle of the throttle where
you turn better, those are the same between the factions.
But the way we treat that from an audio standpoint is quite different. You know,
if you're in a rebel ship, if you listen to it,
there's rattles and clanks and clunks,
and there's this distinct feeling that there's duct tape somewhere behind you
holding that ship together.
Whereas the ties it's, it's clean, it's pristine, precise,
especially with the interceptor, you're going to notice higher pitch.
You're going to notice more kind of clean hums, very little noise in the mix.
[Inaudible].
The whole idea is that these things are engineered to perfection and that's,
you're, you're experiencing kind of, you know,
the Imperial cleanliness and design there.
The alien is one of my favorite ships in all of star Wars.
So we had a lot of fun developing it and it has that very aerodynamic shape.
This thing is just, you know, kind of a wind flying through space. And yeah,
I know there's no air in space,
but there's always that sensation that this thing is incredibly fast at the same
time, it's pretty small. And you have that, that feel that, you know,
one straight blaster bolts gonna make your day real bad.
And we wanted to capture that in all of the tuning and design around the way.
You'll look at the rebel ships and you'll notice that they use different fonts.
So we have all these fonts that are from the end of the universe that you've
seen on screen in the movies.
We've used them in different combinations to help the character of each ship
kind of feel a bit different. It takes, you know,
a team of experts to bring the ships to the players like this.
One of the things that's fun in the game is we've been really careful with our
collision, the actual collision,
geometry around all this sort of stuff you could smash into in the game.
And as a result, if you're in an, a wing,
you can pretty easily fly into say the trench on the side of a star destroyer
flying to that area. That's super tight,
but that's a place where you can legitimately get in there,
potentially lose a pursuer as they might be a bit bigger and smash off the side.
We wanted to lean into that idea of being super fast, super agile,
but small. And you hit like a truck.
So you could have this crazy experience of being very cautious as everything
around you can cause your death pretty easily,
but being able to get in and out and do these awesome,
hidden fade attacks and just make you feel like an ACE.
The cockpit is pretty cramped as well. In VR,
we had to make a few modifications. There's like this metal rim, right?
That like runs kind of across like the glass and where it was positioned in the
Canon ship.
It would be in the way of some of the instruments that the player needs to use.
So we had to move it and thin it and kind of play with that a bit while still
giving you the impression that it's the same position, the same look,
even being able to let you personalize it, like hanging flair,
but not like intrude upon the gameplay elements.
Well,
if this is a real ship that existed and you got a fuzzy walk that you wanted to
put in in the real world,
somebody would sell an attachment to actually hook those things up.
And so that's what we did.
So if you look down and it's just like that classic world war two cockpit stuff
that you'd, you'd expect to see, it's just a great look.
It's the only ship that has a radial speed gauge with an
arrow that actually moves up and down.
And it just gives it that feeling of speed, like almost like a muscle car,
you know? So yeah, I really enjoyed working on the wing.
The bombers are defined by being a bit slower, but heavier a bit.
Tackier built to drop that massive ordinance.
That's going to take out big capital ships,
things like star destroyers and MC 70 fives.
So they might need a little support getting there, but once they get there,
they can do an obscene amount of damage for the bomber. We wanted to make it.
Look different than the interceptor and fighter,
because it has a very different role. And the exterior is also very different.
So we needed to bring that insight as well for the player.
Our job was made easier because the bomber is a bigger ship.
So especially when you're looking around the interior,
you'll see there's actually room where people can sit behind you and all that's
designed. It looks very different than the interior from the other two ships.
Even if you look to the side, you will see that there's,
there's a door and there was the ordinance. You know,
you got all the bombs on the other side and the compartment.
So it makes it already feel quite different just from that.
You can actually go against the capital ships with it.
You can make serious damage. It needed to feel tank here,
kind of the reverse approach that we had for the interceptor, for the bomber.
We went and made the frames of the viewport, thicker more armored,
kind of like he could Ram something and really take a lot of punishment.
Once again, those secondary screens that we introduced,
we gave it a different shape for the bomber or something bulkier to just kind of
confirmed its role on the team.
Well,
the ships that have the off center cockpit like the bomber or the tie Reaper are
quite challenging because as a player,
you don't want to feel like all your control is offset by, you know,
a meter or two from where the ship's actually located.
It becomes incredibly hard to tell, like, can I get through that hole?
I don't know. Where is the hole relative to me?
So what we ended up doing is we have the,
the pilot's seat is technically off center,
but the pivot point for the ship has been moved relative to the,
the broader shape of the ship effectively,
or you're driving it from the center of the ship,
even though your seat is a little offset,
but what we do to make the ships feel weighty is largely playing with the tuning
of their engines. So how fast they accelerate,
how fast they decelerate and how much momentum they preserve when you go into a
different maneuver,
if you're in a bomber and you start to turn the degree to which you have forward
momentum, there helps sell that sense that it's actually kind of a heavy ship.
Obviously the top end speed relative to other ships also helps that sense of
weight. And there's a lot of, uh,
kind of tricks of presentation that help it doesn't make a bit of difference in
the way the ship handles, but in your mind that that sensation,
that it's a kind of beef, your ship helps make it feel slower, feel weightier.
Similarly with the sound design,
when we're using a lot of lower pitches that helps kind of correlate your mind
with the slower BP or stronger ship, uh,
than the more like high-pitched tightly tuned interceptors.
So the Y wing has been a really interesting challenge for us because we're
trying to capture the feel of the ship.
And it's got a lot of similarities with the XYZ in terms of its structure and
cockpit, but you still want it to feel distinctive the cockpit.
Team's done a great job of looking at the instrumentation,
looking at the shape language that you see within that dashboard in the film,
and then trying to make use of that as well as possible,
whether it's the kind of like tube that works its way over the instruments or
the actual shapes you see of the instruments there,
we've tried to make use of those and really lean into them.
So it feels right for a while at the same time,
kind of that heavy structure you have around you are kind of left and right
behind you,
you have a lot less of a window to your astronomic than you would in say an
x-ray.
It's really interesting with the wiling because it's one of the oldest ships
that the rebels have. You can definitely see it in the design.
So it was quite a challenge for us to design something that would keep its
unique character, but make it playable because the ship is devoid of screens.
For starters,
like the only one that you see in the movies is the targeting computer that
comes in from the side. But besides that, it doesn't actually have any displays.
It's kind of like harkens back to the Saifai ships that had basically blinking
lights and these huge computers, right? With like lovers and blinking lights.
You look at the wiring of the cabin for a pilot.
It's been a first file ship over different time periods.
And we've even seen it have two,
two people in there having the pilot and then having like a rear gunner.
So it's a very long cabin. And, uh,
the pilot is kind of sitting with his legs out a bit more compared to some of
the other ships we had to play, you know,
with like the dimensions and do a bunch of tricks to make it feel like the
shots, especially with the ones you see in episode four, but like make it,
make it playable.
So one of the things we did was bring in displays that we'd designed for the
x-ray and layered them with some of the iconic things that were the wiring,
like the tube and dent that cone with the glass lens that we use for the ship
status indicator, even on the screens,
I paid close attention to the patterns that you have on those side panels.
So the painting patterns and those big grip, glass lights that kind of stroke,
we took those patterns and we made vector versions of them.
And we use them as backing for the information under this place was quite a
challenge to be able to try and keep that look,
but introduce screens without, uh, you know, kind of disfiguring the way.
But why wing for the longest time has been our example of how you make two very
different bills using components by default, they're built to be bombers.
They're built to be really good at taking down enemy capital ships,
not as good dogfighting depending on the components.
You can slant them very heavily toward you're taking out capital shifts and just
accept that you're going to be awful in a dog fight and need the support of your
friends,
or you can slant some more the other way and be more of a heavy assault craft,
where you're never going to be as Zippy as an eight wing.
And it's going to be trouble with people, get on your tail.
But if they're dumb enough to come at you from the front,
you can really end their day in a hurry.
What makes a ship part of the support class is that you'll be piloting it to
help your friends and hinder your enemies.
So you're going to have a bunch of tricks up your sleeve that kind of gives you
the edge and slow down your enemies.
Tie Reaper in the Ewing,
both of our support ships actually come from the film rogue one,
and we were really excited to bring them to life in the game because they
haven't had as much exposure yet. The Reaper in particular, just,
you got to love that design. So cool.
I think it's probably my favorite ship on the Imperial side. Originally,
we looked at support and we said, okay, we want kind of the entry-level class,
the class, that's going to be the easiest to use.
It can be helpful for your team, but isn't as effective at killing did not work,
uh, for a couple of reasons.
First is that the X wing of the tie fighter or what everybody knows.
So no matter what we do,
those are going to be the ships that anybody new or more casual is going to
gravitate toward. The other thing is we found that in a dog fighter simply,
you know,
hunting down enemies and shooting them is the most basic thing you can do.
That is the most successful and fundamental part of gameplay.
We ended up pivoting our mindset for support ships,
to be less the entry-level ship, and actually the other way around.
They're more of a high-level ship that takes a bit more skill to use
effectively, but they're the specialists.
You can use a tie Reaper to sort of Batten down the hatches around your area to
put up turrets drop mines, to defend the zone.
You can do it to make your entire team invisible, to enemy radar,
to ionize enemy shields and bring them down to, to, uh, you know, focus fire.
They're very versatile in terms of what they can do with the widest array of
different components that can be equipped.
We were bringing a ship to the screen,
especially it's a cockpit that no one had seen yet.
So the outside has been seen, but like what,
this was going to be news our players,
there were some models that existed because the ship was designed for use for
Jedi fallen order. Our biggest consideration was, uh,
visibility from the ship. We kind of cut the dashboard down and made it shorter.
So the pilot could sit closer to the front windows.
They still look like what you expect when you're seeing it from the outside.
But once again, you know, like little, little tricks, uh,
we make it more accessible for players.
Working on the UN has been interesting because as you may know,
it's a two-seater craft.
And so trying to balance your perspective in a way that feels right,
that feels like you're in the, you know, left-hand seat across the front there,
but also pilots in a way you expect where it's not difficult to fly through a
hole in a structure because, Oh,
actually my center point is over there has been really challenging trying to
make sure that,
that our physics lines up with kind of what your brain expects as a pilot,
especially in VR versus the actual center point of the ship.
The other big challenge is, as you may know,
is that the Ewing has S foils its wings unfold.
So when you wing is jumping into hyperspace,
you've got the wings locked and it's in its iconic U shape.
But once you're ready for combat, they fall back into more of a frankly,
a Y shape, but don't tell the why wings for combat. And that means that their,
their breadth is quite a bit bigger.
So if you're flying through say the interior of a space station, you've got,
gotta be a lot more aware of your surroundings and that you mean that you might
need to in something like in any way, with both the Ewing and the Reaper, uh,
they have places in them to have,
whether it's a copilot or passengers in the back.
And if you look inside them in the game, you do see those seats,
but we don't actually have them filled now partially that's because our game is
set in space. You're not landing on planets.
Wouldn't have anywhere to drop them off.
Not a lot of reason for them to be there fictionally,
but also because from a performance standpoint, the way the game runs,
we're trying to make sure we're giving you the things that matter the most and
giving all the attention there.
So the ships and lasers and explosions that are in front of you,
if we have a high fidelity character, two feet away from you,
everything out of the window is going to have to look worse in order to make
performance space for that character right next to you.
Working on the wing was easier for two reasons. One,
because it's one of the later ships I tackled in production.
So we were already getting really used to finding creative solutions that a
challenge that we faced on the other ships also as luck would have it just the
design would that big central screen. And it has all that, you know,
the mess of wires and connectors, and it has a secondary monitor on a swivel.
I was able to just take that monitor, move it elsewhere,
where it fit with the order that we have four components,
because every ship is different, but gameplay wise, you know, he want people to,
to know that the radar is going to be over on the left.
The speed's going to be on the left because it fits with the controller,
that kind of stuff.
So that let us easily move it around without having to modify it as much.
So what we did for the Ewing is more rescale and move around existing elements.
And we were able to quickly find a home for, uh,
for most of our gameplay components. Uh, I think for the most part,
I only had to modify the top part of the central console.
So it would, uh, it would be able to display our load out.
And we use something that is existing, that you saw,
like this kind of glass part with red lights in the movie,
it was close enough to our laser bar. So it was a really a good fit.
So we've added these two new ships at the time defender and the BYU.
He designed the game around the eight core playable ships. But fortunately,
thanks to all the support of our players,
we're able to add these entirely new ships that fill new niches within the game
play. And they're going to add a lot to the game.
Even though the ships are a part of existing classes,
they play very differently.
They're quite unique and they get their own unique components as well.
A big part of the design of squadrons is about team composition and the way that
you kind of lag your team and the way that you support each other, like, okay,
you know, I'm going to need some people that are handling just enemy ships.
And it needs people that are focusing on the objectives. And so on.
If we added a whole new class,
like we call them the heavier something that compositional picture got a bit
more complicated. So instead we went,
how do we fit these into the existing kind of roles that we have,
but offset enough in that kind of spectrum of design that they all feel unique.
We don't want the tie defender to feel like a it's a tie fighter with a
different cockpit. You want it to feel distinctive,
but we still want to understand the role that, okay,
this is a flexible ship that can be used both offensively and defensively in the
way that a tie fighter I'm a big fan of it from the tie fighter days,
like the PC game tie fighter.
We were so excited to see that come back into Canon and went okay, well,
we've got to let people fly this thing.
The reason we put it in that kind of fighter class is that it is meant to be
flux. It's something that can help offensively defensively,
where it's a bit different than say the tie fighter or tie interceptor is it's
really good within a given area.
It's not as good at getting from point to point heavily leans on boosts and
drift for all your maneuverability. So you can really hold a spot,
but if you need kind of superiority over the large space to hold the front,
you don't want to rely just some defenders,
mix that up with the different teams.
So the tie defender being part of the same line as the tie fighter bomber or
interceptor, obviously has to have a lot of things in common with them.
That's kind of the point of that series for the pilots to just hop in your home.
All the ships in the series,
the main difference was the viewport and also the secondary monitors that we
have on both sides of that central column, that standard and all of them.
So the Thai defender still has that console in the middle,
and it has its own set of handles on the side.
One big thing with a tight offender is it has shields.
So it means it has more power management going on.
And it also has more information that you need to be able to consult as a
player, as we're flying that, that ship.
We had fun playing with different shapes and patterns.
We found one that boat felt robust enough to kind of feel like this is a ship
that can take punishment, but also,
still felt aggressive a bit closer to the Ty interceptor than the bottom ones.
We want it to look like the empire spend more money on the ship.
There's a little bit more technology going on a little bit more stuff built in
compared to the other three cortex buyers.
The ship status indicator. If you look at the other three basic ties,
besides the Reaper,
what we're showing you is a silhouette of the ship seen from the front because
the defender has shields. We want it to show you a top-down view.
So it would be clear right off the back of your looking at your front and rear
shields. I love it,
silhouette so aggressive and all those those spikes when you see it from the
top. But it's also a very challenging shape to work with, uh,
for the UI to try and, you know,
like surrounding with the shields and fit that nicely within the screen.
So I spent quite a bit of time doing different iterations and
patterns and, and line art to that would, uh,
that would really go well with the silhouette and still stay clear for me.
In rebels, the tide offenders, just straight up,
better than the other ties in the context of a competitive game that doesn't
work grading. It's like, all right, well,
you've got five ships take that one's totally superior.
So what we've done lore wise is that after Thrones initiative, uh, you know, uh,
spoilers the things go sideways on the fall that defender, uh,
initiatives put out a service, but the plans are still around.
So in our time period, when the empire is not doing so well,
the plans still exist, but they don't have the resources they once did.
So you're getting kind of a second generation more suited for mass production
version. The whole game was designed to make you feel like an ACE pilot,
but the defender is a whole other level.
Now the elite within the ACE pilot group, when I really master that ship,
which is a great feeling,
the cool thing about the B wing is it's the last ship from the return of the
Jedi era that we wanted to bring to the light that we never got a chance to do
with the core game.
So the B wing is really cool because it's got this unique gyroscopic cockpit.
You can actually keep your cockpit stable,
but control the entire rest of the ship around the cockpit. Now, partially,
this is just cool, just for fun, but also you can be using this tactically.
So it's something that improves your missile evasion.
It's something you can use to aim your bombs.
So you can have your ship like aiming upward flight under a ship and shoot your
bombs straight up, for example. And beyond that,
it actually is increasing the rest of your ammo. So if you take that component,
the one that lets you control your gyroscopic cockpit,
it's doubling whatever your other auxiliary does.
So we were wondering maybe we would only allow you to have it vertically or
horizontal, and it would just kind of ease by itself in between those motions.
Once you triggered it, or we could allow total control, I'm pretty,
pretty stoked that we were actually able to allow you granular controls.
You can actually place it at any angle that you want. As you're piloting.
We decided to go kind of old school with a dial that looks like some something
you'd have on an old fighter plane.
And you actually have a needle that's like a B wing silhouette shape.
And you see it rotate around the dial. So you get like this precise feedback.
You got a bubble cockpit.
So if you're doing free look or especially if you're in VR,
you can be just looking out the window is that as that big wing is moving.
You'll sit like, you know, block out the light, like across your dashboard, you.
Feel the rumble of using your controller.
And you've got that kind of a shuttering metal scraping sound.
As the entire ship moves around, you can be firing your lasers,
you're being Canon or whatever, while you're rotating the wing.
And so you see the lasers kind of spiraling around your cockpit as that's
rotating, and you're still fire. The ship is ungainly.
You go flying into a tight tunnel, like in our new map, foster Haven,
you've got to really be paying attention to what are the constraints of that
ship? Are you just smack into a wall? And so having that,
that level of situational awareness,
having the new instrumentation that lets you actually control and be aware of
where the rest of your ship is, uh,
is a whole new kind of experience with the B wing.
That's really unlike anything else in the game.
The references we had were mainly the ships were built for the original trilogy.
So you've never seen them into movie like the inside,
but they were built like as part of that, that ship,
they were using photos outside shots as they were flying through space.
And then, uh,
there was references from the rebels show for the prototype of the B wing.
From a fictional standpoint, the blade wing was the prototype.
So what we're trying to capture is more of the standard B wing that comes along
a bit later.
And also because there's just something cool about feeling like when you saw
return of the Jedi,
that cockpit was actually there and that'd be when you just couldn't quite see
it because of the camera work.
And we're finally getting to sort of reveal that to the world, you know,
very much in first person for the first time, the BYU.
Being one of the leaderships to be introduced,
it's little subtle things that it will set it apart,
making the screens a bit higher resolution and playing, you know,
with the type of CRT or LCD monitors you're seeing in some of the panels,
the beeping has a mix of like small CRTs for like it's radar and then it ships
status indicator. Uh,
but then it does have a nice big LCD display for the combat screen,
closer to what you'd see on the wing.
So the B wing in lore is, is a bomber. You know, it's, it's a bomber clash,
this whole craft, but being, being a great bomber is a big part of its identity.
So we wanted to keep that concept. Um, but it's also such a unique shift.
You know, it's something that a lot of people love are fans of wanting to play.
We've got a lot of feedback if the feeling, where is it? Okay.
We put it in guys. It's going to be okay.
It's that idea of being able to control your bombs specifically that from,
from a mechanical standpoint, that, well, with the ship,
we thought that was such a good fit that it made.
It made sense to really lean into that bomber room. The other thing is,
if you look at the design of our ships,
the Y wing has always been intended to be kind of a spectrum between going all
bomber and more of a dog fighter or somewhere in between.
We give you quite a bit of flexibility with the B wing.
We've gone even further to the right, so it can dog fight,
but at the most it's going to be a backline fighter.
That's kind of providing it like artillery support.
Whereas on the other extreme,
it is a bomber that is good for dropping bombs and nothing else.
And you darn well better escort it in terms of team composition.
The thing with the B wing is that it is the farthest thing over on the extreme
of kind of the, I just murder people too. I just murder capital ships,
a spectrum of different shifts.
And so it's something that doesn't work well on its own is a ship that benefits
tremendously from being paired with the UN and to a lesser extent by being
paired with other shifts that can support and protect it on way to the desk,
to the destination. Similarly, you can set it up to be more of a dog fighter,
but even in that case,
it's not going to be flying around in the middle of everything.
The way that an a wing would, it stays more at a distance.
And while everyone else is keeping the enemy busy, it just guns them down,
you know, tremendous artillery.
So it's very much a ship that leans into teamwork. Uh,
you don't want to run the wings without the support of your buddies.
[Inaudible].
And that was every Starfighter in star Wars, squadrons.
We hope this has helped you understand the game a little bit better and brought
that galaxy far, far away, a little bit closer to home.